el área sembrada con coca en Colombia
llegó a su nivel más alto en dos décadas
de monitoreo según la oficina de las
Naciones Unidas contra la droga y el
delito el área sembrada con coca la
materia prima de la cocaína se disparó
un 43% entre 2020 y 2021 hasta las
204.000 hectáreas se estima que el
potencial de producción es de 1400
toneladas de clorhidrato de cocaína un
14% más que en el año 2020 para la
administración de Gustavo Petro que ha
calificado la lucha contra las drogas
como un fracaso ha propuesto regular los
narcóticos crear programas de
sustitución voluntaria y aumentar la
financiación social en las áreas de
producción continuamos haciendo lo mismo
que se ha venido haciendo en los últimos
10 o 20 años el resultado no va a
cambiar
Si queremos revertir esa cifras tenemos
que hacer algo distinto algo nuevo
nariño y putumayo fronterizos con
Ecuador son los principales
departamentos del país con narco
cultivos según la agencia de la ONU
mientras el catatumbo una región en el
departamento de norte de Santander
fronterizo con Venezuela sigue la lista
sin embargo Leonardo Correa director del
sistema de monitoreo de cultivos
ilícitos dijo en diálogo con France 24
que no todo es negativo en esta lucha la
evaluación de una política de drogas no
puede estar basada únicamente en la
cantidad de hectáreas de coca que hay
Colombia una vez más es el récord
mundial de incautaciones de cocaína más
de 600 toneladas de cocaína fueron
incautadas y yo creo que entonces lo que
tenemos es una situación de un balance
en el cual en zonas muy específicas del
país tenemos esta situación de
incremento pero al mismo tiempo tenemos
unos territorios que permanecen libres
de coca
sin embargo las cifras de la ONU
contradicen los informes publicados por
Estados Unidos en junio de este año
cuando anunció que la producción
potencial de cocaína cayó en 2021 a 972
toneladas métricas y la superficie de
cultivos de Coca llegó a las 234.000
hectáreas